und wir beginnen unsere sendung aber mit
diesen bildern aus schwerte wir sehen
hier einen mann der mit einem messer
bewaffnet ist und sek beamte die auf ihn
zustürmen der 65 45 jährige wie gesagt
mit einem messer bewaffnet er flüchtet
vor den beamten und dann wenige
augenblicke später wird er von den
beamten niedergeschossen ja das ganze
passierte bereits am freitagmorgen die
bilder wurden von einer augenzeugin zu
uns gespielt und wir möchten direkt
weiter schalten zu frank schneider
unserem bild chefreporter frank wir
haben die bilder gesehen wie ist denn
das genaue vorgehen gewesen des sek
erzielt davon eben noch mal eine
rekapitulieren man sieht ja wie die
beamten sich nähern ist und insgesamt
vier beamte in voller montur in
schutzausrüstung auch mit einer langen
stange man sieht es hier und der täter
spricht gerade mit der anderen seite
dort steht die verhandlungsgruppe das
sind die beiden ablenken wollen damit
die person annäherung er merkt dass aber
und dann sieht man hier wie er wegrennt
und da muss jetzt vorstellen wir haben
andere 420 kilo schutzausrüstung man
denkt ja wieso läuft er so schnell weg
der sich viel schneller hat diese gut
ausgebildeten und wirklich extrem
trainierten sek und das liegt aber daran
die schleppen jeder 20 kilometer
und der steht wohl stark unter adrenalin
und läuft dann eben sehr schnell weg und
dann hört man mehrere schlussfolgern die
ersten schüsse die man hört sind relativ
leise das ist mit einem taser man
versucht es mit einem taser und
sozusagen außer gefecht zu setzen das
hat aber wohl nicht funktioniert weil
eine relativ dicke jacke und diese
kleinen jahr teile wenn man sie so
nennen möchte nicht durch die jacke
durchgegangen sind das heißt er war erst
mal unbeeindruckt man versucht hier
erstmal nicht sofort scharf zu schießen
und dann hat man auf dem flug eben
scharf geschossen aber nur auf die beine
um die beine getroffen weil das sieht
man ja hier jetzt auch noch mal erlaubt
ihr mit diesen langen messer in der hand
dazu schwenkt dann nach rechts rüber
läuft da einfach mal gleich auf einen
polizisten zu und dann war das problem
als erste über den zaun gehen da steht
noch eine polizistin glaube ich ist das
und dahinter war eine supermarkt zeitung
eine pizzeria auch unbeteiligte waren
und da war die große sorge der polizei
dass er daneben auch unbeteiligte
angreifen könnt und deshalb hat man dort
auf ihn geschossen und hat ihnen dann in
den beinen getroffen und ihnen so außer
gefecht gesetzt ist schwer verletzt aber
eben nicht in lebensgefahr
jetzt sieht man relativ zu anfang des
videos wenn die beamten ihnen gerade so
mehr oder weniger über diese wiese
hinweg verfolgen dass sie so etwas
relativ langes in der hand haben was so
aussieht wie ein speer genau hier sehen
wir das was genau ist das denn und wofür
ja das ist auch eine schutzausrüstung
wenn man so möchte wird bei sogenanntem
sata haben wir das problem in der kurzen
distanz können sie extrem großen schaden
anrichten insbesondere bei so einem
großen messer das kinderhaus aus dem
messerblock das ist das 20 zentimeter
klingenlänge und damit zuzustechen ist
natürlich brandgefährlich und deshalb
haben die polizisten diese langen
stangen dabei um den täter mit diesen
stangen auf distanz zu halten dass sie
eben nicht mit dem messer verletzen kann
und das behindert natürlich beim
hinterherlaufen und heimlich wie gesagt
auch die schutzausrüstung die schweren
schutzwesten die helme die rucksäcke die
sie zum teil auffangen
das ist natürlich alles extrem schwer
und deswegen sieht man hier jetzt auch
noch mal wie eben sozusagen den einen
meter ab nimmt auch die distanz und als
sie dann merken er geht auch noch über
den zaun geht jetzt in einem bereich der
nicht mehr sicher ist hat man sich dann
entschieden in der dicht kampfunfähig zu
schießen und hat dann auch seine beine
gezielt man hört dass auch an dem lang
der schüsse am anfang diese these
schüsse sind relativ da man hört gerade
den entschluss er ist relativ laut das
ist eine mitteldistanz war heißt die das
schon etwas größeres kaliber und damit
hat man jetzt eben versucht ihn außer
gefecht zu setzen hat es ja dann auch
geschafft er hat ja dann keine weiteren
personen verletzen können das problem
war die kollegin neuester hat sie eben
schon beschrieben er gilt eben auch als
möglicherweise der wald tätig er war
vorbestraft sein
er hat mehrfach schon auch gedroht er
hat auch den polizisten gedroht deren am
anfang ganz normal kontrollieren wollten
deswegen wusste man nicht wie gefährlich
ist er ist er möglicherweise aufgrund
der situation die jetzt eskaliert auch
völlig außer kontrolle
wolfgang mock und ist hat man sich
entschieden in kampfunfähig zu schießen
und zum glück nur schwer verletzt und
eben nicht getötet
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren